the boys one of the hottest new subaru
shows out there
i just finished season two and after the
final episode i thought to myself
why is the show so addicting to watch i
literally burned through season one
within a couple days
and season two was just as mesmerizing
that's the last one
satisfying finale that's it then there
has to be another one there's not
i get my job we're losing our house they
owe us
there are multiple things that i think
this show does amazingly and are also
very unique
so i wanted to analyze them in this
video i've whittled it down to three
reasons
as to why the boys is so addicting and
the first main one
is the show's unique style and tone
this is a show that is very crude
graphic and bizarre
this fundamental combination crafts a
very unique dna that infects
every scene in the show a part of the
fun that is derived from the show is
that it is not afraid of being too
bizarre
it is constantly trying to shock its own
audience with something they've never
seen before
while also having smart writing to
justify the bizarre elements
like the deep having self-reflecting
dialogue with his gills
you deserve to be loved kevin but that
starts with you
but it doesn't stop there having an
emotional dialogue seen inside a dead
whale
they have it the deep saving and
flirting with a dolphin
they have it homeland are fantasizing
about killing thousands of people
they have it there are so many absurd
and crazy moments that are perfectly
accompanied by good writing so it just
feels natural for the show
since they have this crazy tone that is
set every scene feels kind of
unpredictable
because in the back of your mind you
think that oh hilly won't kill
translucent here there's no way
translucent is a superhero
or how are they going to get out of this
dangerous scenario
oh let's just use a super baby with
laser eyes as a weapon
that was diabolical all of these scenes
and solutions feel very creative
and watching all these creative moments
fall together with its bizarre and funny
tone makes for a very satisfying watch
through
at no point does it feel unnatural that
the show is having a heart-to-heart
moment between two characters
while next to an actual heart it is just
a part of the show's tone that is
established early on primarily through
the perspective of billy butcher
he gives us a lens as to how messed up
and crude the superheroes actually
are this is a very unique perspective on
the superhero genre
also this is mostly branching into my
next point which is the subversion of
genre we get a realistic viewpoint as to
how superheroes would most likely act in
real life
we peel back the curtain and the show
exposes us to all their flaws
and this is another thing that makes all
the superhero characters so compelling
and
interesting to watch we have eight train
who is a drug addict speedster
homelander who is a crazy superhero
seeking validation
the deep who's just an overall scumbag
starlight
who hates the corporate life of being a
superhero and is actively trying to
sabotage it
maeve an indestructible superhero who is
so beat down by the corporate life of
being one
and black noir being black noir these
are all
characters with realistic and tangible
flaws
they are all compelling characters
because they have active weaknesses
in comparison to a lot of other
superheroes who have very boring and
simple character flaws
i think it is pretty objective that most
of these flaws are more interesting than
superman being allergic to some alien
rocks
so in general most of the superhero
characters in the boys subvert the
general foundation of superhero
characters within its own genre
this is interesting because they come
off as real people and they don't feel
indestructible
maybe it's because the seven might just
be a squad of manky roid heads
also one of the show's active goals for
its main characters
is killing and taking down the corrupt
superheroes
so by establishing that it is
accomplishable to exploit each and every
superhero
it gives the protagonist a fighting
chance against the antagonists
so in its core dna this is basically an
underdog story of some guys trying to
kill some soups
that pitch in a nutshell is pretty
awesome and they even deliver on that
obstacle within the third
episode of season one with the death of
translucent the characters are actually
able to overcome
the seemingly impossible task of taking
down a superhero
through the show's good writing the
viewers are constantly engaged and are
addicted to see how the boys come up
with taking down
vaude and any superhero in their way
this primary obstacle that our
protagonists have to overcome
is very addicting because they are at a
constant disadvantage
and this is where the show's crude
creativity comes in for example in
season 2
the deep seemingly stops the boys and
blocks their method of escape
but what bright idea does butcher have
just ram the boat into the whale and
yellow that [ __ ]
and neutralize the blockade
because the show's crazy violent and
crude style it opens up the possibility
for practically anything to happen
and that is truly addicting to watch
practically in every episode we see
something that is crazy and unique and
through the show's good writing it
always has a place
in the narrative so for the next reason
as to why the boys is so addicting to
watch is that the production value of
the show
is really high for tv shows we are
generally used to low budget episodes
where the production value is somewhat
lackluster
seeing shows with higher budgets is very
refreshing and they stand out in
comparison to other shows
for the boys though there are two main
reasons as to why that production value
is so high
first let's talk about the visual
effects good visual effects
are in very few shows and are typically
used in blockbuster movies
this is generally because it is very
expensive to pull off
and they are not required to tell most
stories however
for the boys the visual effects are an
integral part of the show because they
enhance and tell the stories of the
superhero characters
by having seamless and high quality
effects for these characters we can get
fully immersed
in their story the first episode alone
is a perfect hook into the show and
includes some of the best vfx within the
whole season
two examples in the first episode is the
introduction of maeve in the death of
robin for the introduction of maeve the
creators of the show are hooking you
with some crazy visual spectacle to set
a high quality president for the show
this shot alone would normally be found
in blockbuster movies but the fact that
this isn't a tv show
it blows your expectations away you are
now watching something that is very
captivating for tv standards
for the death of robin similar to the
first point it has crazily good visual
effects that look great
but it also offers something much more
unique most blockbuster movies are pg-13
and we mostly get watered down by
non-graphic visual effects
especially for superhero movies this is
what the boyz has to offer that is very
unique in terms of visual effects
it perfectly satisfies a want for more
adult-like content in the superhero
genre
and it is able to create a more gritty
and realistic tone
we actually get to experience an r-rated
superhero story about corruption and
power
the only other notable adult movies in
the superhero genre are logan and
deadpool
and from their success it is clear that
there is an underlying want for this
type of content
going back to the vfx the show also
utilizes its vfx very casually to give
the world more authenticity
this raises the production value because
the show isn't afraid of spending the
vfx budget on moments that aren't tied
to action
this is overall very good for world
building because it normalizes any
extraordinary aspects in the world
and makes them seem very seamless an
example of this is in season 1 where
butcher and huey get into a super club
and they are all using their powers
naturally
the vfx here isn't used for crazy visual
spectacle but instead
to actualize the world that we are
experiencing the show at no point feels
restricted by its vfx budget
and they can tell an authentic and
compelling story because of that
for the next point about how the
production value is so high are the
actors
firstly they have carl freaking urban
this is a man who has been in star trek
the mcu
dread riddick and the lord of the rings
to name a few
this is a great actor that we are
dealing with he brings so much charisma
and complex depth to an intricate
character that seems very
hard to play you could take the blue
pill
or was it the red poo anyway take the
other pill and quit being a kid which
pill do you want me to take
just quit being a [ __ ] that's what i'm
saying whenever he is on screen we are
glued to his performance
and most of his lines and moments are so
memorable that it turns into meme
culture
like we literally have him in season 2
where he's just sipping tea
and that becomes one of the most iconic
moments of the season
the casting all around is pretty much
perfect but i want to put my focus onto
one more person
and that person is anthony starr he
seems to be one of the lesser known
casting picks but his performance as
homelander is honestly one of the best
villain performances in the superhero
genre
the reason why is that he is a very
interesting character study
this is a man who grew up in a lab and
because of that is very
unhinged and as a superhero with
unlimited power
that is extremely terrifying
on top of it being such a great
performance the show's length allows his
character to evolve exponentially
in comparison to any other villain in
the movie format
currently for his first couple seasons i
think he is definitely amongst some of
the greats like thanos joker and loki
and he even has more seasons to expand
his character and for any story one of
the reasons why it's so addicting is
that you need to have a great villain to
drive the conflict
also as a side note they basically have
gus fring from breaking bad running the
evil corporation
so what's not to like here especially
since this is an r-rated show
it allows for the corruption and evil
side of pulamander to have practically
no
limit and with no limit to homelander
that basically makes him even more
menacing we never know how far he will
go and that makes him truly terrifying
on both sides you have very intriguing
protagonists and antagonists
and because of the good writing it
basically allows for infinite
possibilities for interesting
storytelling
but yeah this is why i think the boys is
so addicting to watch
it's bizarre crude and graphic style and
tone makes it feel really unique
it subverts the superhero genre and it
has a very high production value
on top of these three reasons i also
think that the themes explored in the
show are very captivating like
corruption corporate greed and one's
belonging
it's just an overall fun show and i hope
it is able to retain its quality over
the next seasons
you